of the morning is going to be elon lobel
will be my future colleague at nyu stern
so
he graduated from mit and his research
interests are in pricing learning
markets networks and mechanical design
and hopefully talking to us about some
cool work on sort of contextual inverse
optimization
cool take it away thank you thank you
very much uh jackie
uh thank you everybody
so um
let me tell you what the paper is about
and then i'll explain what these words
mean here there's a lot of words in this
title uh so here uh in this data driven
decision process framework
our typical setup is something like a
contextual bandit right where we like we
get some context which is an action
and then we get a reward
and but there are many settings of
interest where you can't actually
observe rewards and this is going to be
our theme here
and in settings where you can't observe
your words and i'll give you some
examples in a second what other feedback
might you be able to use to learn from
and
what we're going to study here are
settings where
instead of learning the reward you learn
after the fact what you should have done
so this is what we're going to call
contextual inverse optimization you know
and in the next slides can be clear
what's the mapping between
the terminology and the problem but let
me give you some applications
so one application in economics and like
choice modeling
is learning from revealed preferences
so
i see people
observing bundles of goods and they have
prices and they choose to buy some
subsets of those goods
i never observed their rewards right i
don't know how much utility they got out
of it but i know what they bought
so i can use the fact that they've
bought bundles of code to try to make
inference about what optimization
problem they were solving what utility
function they had
um
in robotics people use this stuff a lot
uh it's often called inverse
reinforcement learning there where um
it's very hard to give a utility
function to a robot or an autonomous
vehicle but you can you can tell an
autonomous vehicle
um you made the right thing here you
should have done this so again so the
the idea here is i'm never gonna
i'm never gonna observe exactly uh the
utility function that i need but i have
sort of like if i chose an arm i know
like no no i picked their own garments
to pick this up
and you can think of applying this for
medicine to like
for many con for many uh applications in
medicine you don't really know
if a medicine worked it didn't work
right the doctor prescribes something
but you can tell a robot no no you
prescribed the wrong thing you should
have prescribed this and stuff
and and how we're going to think about
this mathematically so in every period
so we're going to consider two versions
an offline an online version but you can
think that in every period we want to
solve a problem of this kind
and here is why uh the name contextual
because every period they have a set of
actions and a context function
and the problem is we don't know a class
there's some cost vector i don't know
that i need to learn
but i do observe the set of actions the
contextual function
and an optimal action after the period
after i make an action i observe some
optimal solution of this problem
so it's inverse optimization because i
observe
a solution of an optimization and then i
want to learn the cost factor and it's
contextual because i have these f
functions
and and just to keep a problem in mind
you can think of the learning from
review preferences example
like this
like every period uh
you have a bundle of goods with prices
so there's a bundle of goods with prices
and you have a budget and let's say
there's a and and i want to know the
values of the features of the goods and
this matrix v will map
from features to products and then i see
which products you buy and i want to
learn how much you value different
features
another example is i want to understand
how harvard chooses its class i have no
idea how the harvard community what the
harvard committee is optimizing but i
want to try to
understand what it is that they're
optimizing for so i know that they have
a budget of people and they care about
sat scores athletic ability and a bunch
of other features and i might be able to
observe what they where they accepted
and who they rejected and from that i
want to sort of like
try to make some inference about what is
the problem that we're trying to solve
and
quickly uh the literature on inverse
optimization dates back to this paper
from 20 years ago by ahuja in orleans
where given a given an optimal action
you want to estimate a cost factor
there's uh
there's a much more modern treatment for
example by timothy chan
out of uh the university of toronto uh
in terms of closer stuff to us is this
paper by espahaniaro which is a pretty
celebrated paper it won the the
lancaster prize which is closest to our
offline model
and the closest paper to ours is
actually going to be this barman pokut
and schneider html paper which is going
to be closest to our online model and
what they do is that they do a reduction
to gradient descent and they propose an
algorithm for this
uh there's also a literature on
contextual pricing and contextual search
sahara versus hara
over there
uh
uh hara is going to be presenting about
this stuff later on
and
um
i'm going to argue we're going to
leverage some of the techniques from
this literature but i'm going to argue
that the problem is actually quite
different because they have a lot less
knowledge about the problem than here
and there's also a big literature in cs
and inverse reinforcement learning
structure predictions and i'm not gonna
stop you and i forgot to mention that
the
the actual brain power behind this
problem behind the salt paper it's not
me it's yuri over there yuri can you say
hi to everybody
good thank you so yuri is uh you is a
phd student of colombia he is uh
he's the person who should get the tough
questions as uh fifa said
and um
what is it that we do here what are our
main results for the offline model
we're going to do some geometry here and
i'm going to propose some geometric
notion of how informative a data set is
and then use this notion to characterize
and minimize regret
and then for the online studying the
state-of-the-art result is this order uh
severity regret from barman
which assumes linear context functions
so we're going to generalize to an
ellipses context functions and we're
going to get logarithmic regress so we
have an exponential gain here from
square root t to log t regret but we pay
in terms of
the geometry is going to give us some
dimension coefficients in the regress
so let's uh let's get started with the
offline setting
the offline setting i'm giving a bunch
of data and i want to know how good can
i make a future prediction based on this
data so i'm given feasible actions for a
bunch of observations the context
function for each problem and what is an
optimal action in each of these problems
and all of these satisfy this equation
as i described before
and given this i can use i'm going to
use the letter d to describe my data and
let's just see zero to define my initial
cost my initial set of possible costs
and let's normalize this to be on like
on a sphere
uh because i'm never going to observe
rewards right so if the cost double i'm
not going to observe anything different
right so you can assume that this is
this lives on the surface of a sphere
and
given the set of uh
given the set of initial costs and my
data set this is the set of feasible
costs that
that i might have given the data
observed
here
so this is everything that i can
know
based on my data
a policy is a mapping from my data set
and the next problem i'm going to face
what i should choose in that problem
there is no noise or there is there is
no noise in this model so uh this
literature
the barman paper our paper doesn't have
noise we're working on a version now for
a noisy version but for today there's
not going to be any noise you observe
exact actions which is kind of like the
most classical version of inverse
optimization
but obviously uh to make this practical
you got to figure out how to add noise
here but but today there's no noise in
this presentation
and you can ask hara she's really good
at adding noise to things and today
they have because i've done other work
in contextual pricing search and they've
added like several versions of noise and
those things
in their own work uh
so
our regret is going to be very natural
right how much
how much our cost is minus how much
would be if we knew c star how much the
optimal feature is and this is going to
be an adversarial model so i'm not going
to make any stochastic assumptions about
how the data generated so i want to know
like the worst case if nature throws me
the worst problem and the worst cost
here how much is my regret so wcr stands
for worst case regret
and this is pretty general this is the
the set of all measurable sets within a
bounded set and this is the set of all
electricity functions
so in uh in an adversarial setting i
can't do the usual thing that you're
doing learning which is say as n grows
how much better is my data and why can't
i do that because nature can be mean to
me the nature can send me the same
problem over and over
so there's no notion that like as then
grows i can do better right so
only if nature gives me better data i
can know better so it's possible that i
can learn nothing so i need some sort of
notion that if the data is informative i
can do well
and i'm going to have to define what
does it mean for the data to be
informative and here's where we're going
to use some high dimensional geometry
here to try to think about
um what is a notion of of an informative
data center
um so the
in this whole literature
everybody works with a set of proxy
policies and what is the proxy policies
the set of actions is is too unwieldy to
work with because they are the action
sets keeps jumping around from problems
of problem so what you work on the
typical approach in this literature and
then we're going to follow this too is
you guess a cost vector i'm going to say
i think this is the true cost vector
and this is what we call the proxy cost
factor and based on this my guess of
what the cost factor is i'm going to
choose an optimal action
and given if i have
a proxy cost and a true cost
then i can define some sort of like
worst case loss here right what is the
worst case loss the worst case loss is
like
if my class is this nature and the
through classes is how bad can i do
and it's not too hard to argue that
if i optimize if i think about what is a
worst case policy i can think about it
in the sense i can transform this into
this minimax problem
over proxy costs
there's a restriction here that i'm
restricting myself to proxy policies but
then i can turn this into a minimax
policy on these vectors
and this is going to be nice because i
can use i can bound this loss
based on the on the geometry of the
problem that is theta is the angle
between the two vectors so the loss
is uh given by the sine of the angle
between the two if the angle is small
enough if the angle is big
one is the worst case so i can't do
anything
so if they took so it's pretty intuitive
right if if i think the crosses and the
tripos is not too far away my loss is
not that bad
and it's actually it's intuitive but
it's actually hard actually the way we
prove this number is we had
semi-definite programming and if you
have questions about that yuri is the
man
uh but so the the technical work to
prove this is harder than it looks based
on the statement of the results but i'm
going to take this for granted which is
this notion like i can reduce the notion
that problem to a geometric problem and
remember we reduced first to a minimax
problem over the loss and now we're
going to turn this
into something about angles
so now what i care about is the sort of
like min max of the angle so remember
there's a sign here but i can take the
sign out because i don't care about the
term or sinus monotone
right i only care about this for small
thetas where sine is monotone
so i can turn this into a minimax
over angles between the true cost and
the actual cost and i'm going to define
this notion here this minimax
could be the uncertainty angle
and the minimizer to see how the
minimizes as we call the uncertainty the
circumcenter
and it's pretty intuitive to understand
what this means when you think of a
geometric so imagine you have a set of
so i said the costs live on the surface
of a ball
so the set of costs
let's say it's here so what i want to do
is fit the smallest cone i can
around the set
the smallest revolution cones the
smallest second-order corner can fit
around the set
and this and the axis of this uh
this cone is going to be in my
circumcenter
and the angle here is my uncertainty
angle
so what is this notion here saying
that if
if i have a data set here and if i can
fit it within a small cone i can do
pretty well
if i have to fit it on a large cone i'm
going to do pretty badly so the offline
problem reduces this geometry problem of
angles right can i can i sort of like is
there a small angle is there some vector
that has a small angle to everything in
there
yes
would you like to comment a bit why
angles instead of like something else
the difference between the two
c hat and c star
y angle instead of uh
it's on the surface of a ball
so
we're going to call the proxy policy
where i choose my proxy cost the
circumstantial policy and naturally from
what i said the optimal proxy policy is
a circumcenter policy so if i have an
offline layer what i want to use is a
circumstantial policy just sort of like
yes this
try to fit it inside a cone pick the
axis of the cone and guess that number
and this gives me my worst case regret
we wrote the theorem here in terms of
proxy policies we have a more slightly
more complicated statement in terms of
true in terms of general policies i'm
not going to present it here but the the
result
extends to general policies with some
slight caveats
and now um
the attorney angle defines a regret and
this bound is non-trivial if and only if
the set of costs live in a point of code
so that's
that's the offline problem what we can
say about now i want to jump to the
online problem which i think is more
interesting a more challenging one here
so in the online problem i'm going to
have key periods
every period i'm giving a feasible
action and a context function and then
i'm going to choose an action in this
feasible set
and after the period i observe what an
optimal action would have been
and now i can i can repeat some of the
same argument my information set is now
um
now what the feasible set of actions the
context function what nature did and
what i did in each period plus the
problem i'm facing today
and i can create this set of just like
before the set of vectors that is
consistent with my purity information
set
a policy is a mapping from uh the
information set what i should do and i
care about regret which is very
naturally defined as as like how much
i'm i'm i'm losing minus how much nature
is losing and my objective is to
minimize worst-case regret so nature
again adversarial
bandits kind of thing here
so so when we try to look at this
problem our first approach is try to use
the techniques from the previous work
that we did in like with actual pricing
contextual search but the first thing
you start to realize is that actually
you have very little control over the
feedback
because you have really no direct
control for the feedback because look
look at the problem here so this is your
information set and look what shows up
in your information set
which is uh the feasible set
the context function and the optimal
action but your own actions the things
you've chosen don't show up here
and this is different than pricing right
in pricing you choose a price and you
learn if the valuation is below or above
the price so you can you have much more
control over the learning process in a
pricing problem on a search problem here
you don't actually
uh gain you don't you don't control
anyway this uh information set
so this implies that maybe you should
ignore the dynamics and do something
greedy
this statement is false
but i'm going to pretend it's true for a
little bit that i does something greedy
is good
uh
there is going to be a way to control
the information set it's very subtle and
it's part of it's part of how we get
there but for now i'm going to pretend i
want to do something greedy
because i'm taking this view oh i don't
x5 doesn't show up here so i'm not
saying i'm going to ignore expire and
just a greedy thing and the greedy thing
is circumcenter right so the offline
optimal
is the same thing i should do if i if my
game ended today i should just do the
offline optimal thing right use all
previous history so
so the offline is a key ingredient here
so i should do this circumstance yeah
just make sure this is the feedback that
i see here
you see you see what problems you've
chosen at the beginning of the period
you see which problem you should choose
to probably should solve and at the end
of the period you see what you should
have done so it's exogenous they don't
control at all
yeah
that's major choice
it looks exogenous but i'm going to
argue you actually have some controversy
in in a very roundabout way so that's
part of the interesting thing here in
this world
but at this point it should look
exciting yes right there this should be
a stationary function
it's not stationary adversary checking
for whatever he wants
it's a worst case uh
i'm not making any probabilistic
assumptions
so now now i'm gonna uh the next theorem
says that the circumstantial policy
fails miserably in this problem
and what do you mean by feels miserable
you get regret that is linearity
so the greedy policy does not work and
and how do we prove that this doesn't
work which is nature can
construct instances where you get every
period lots of regret and you learn
almost nothing
and and i'm going to walk you through
how this works how uh how nature can do
this but the instance looks kind of like
this so the set of feasible cluster here
or this
or this blue set and the circumcenter is
going to be this uh vector here so the
circumference might be strange that it's
on the boundary but actually the
circumcenter of the set is on the
boundary
and this is going to play a key role in
the story here
so how does nature how does nature mess
you up in this model
which is suppose your set of feasible
actions in period 1 is 0 or x1 or x1 is
over here
and there's no context function the
context function as i did the identity
function
now
the proxy cost i said is over here so
you do the inner product between this
and this and that's negative that's
better than choosing zero so you choose
x1 which was actually next one
nature on the other hand knows that for
class here no nature two is a zero
because there's a positive class here so
so nature is causing you to get quite a
bit of regret here by choosing this cost
and the problem is nature gave you
almost no information
so what is the feedback that you have
here you know that uh this was worse
than choosing zero
so you know you know you can add a
hyperplane here
that is orthogonal to x1 but look at
what you're cutting you're cutting
nothing out you're cutting like this
essentially at the circumcenter so the
problem is nature can give you a lot of
regret and essentially cut almost almost
nothing out of your set
so so what control do we have if that
doesn't work
is this a dome problem and if it was i
wouldn't be here
uh so let's assume that you made a bad
choice so you got so if you made a good
choice you don't get regret i don't care
so let's say that he made a bad choice
in a period
by the optimality of xc star this
inequality is true
which means i can add this to my on i
can add this constraint to my
knowledge set
and i'm going to call this like the
difference in actions here so difference
in actions in the products you start is
negative
and we do have some control over this
and what is the control that we have
over this
because by the optimality of xt pi with
respect to my proxy cost
i get that this inner product here is
positive
so the difference in action inner
productivity pi is positive
and if you come to think about this what
am i doing
i know that i'm adding a constraint
of uh of this kind difference in action
c star is negative and i know the
difference in activity pi is positive
and imagine that these were strict
inequalities here
this would mean that nature needs to cut
off
the proxy costs at every period nature
needs to throw away the proxy costs in
each period
it's not exactly through that because
this can be equality so nature can throw
the proxy cost at a boundary so what
this is saying is that whenever i choose
a proxy cost nature needs to flow needs
to cut through it needs to throw my
proxy cost to the boundary
so
so when we don't learn much
is when uh the proxy cost is right on
the boundary
so that was the problem here the proxy
cost was right on the boundary so i do
have
uh an exploration exploitation trade-off
here which is if i want to exploit i
want to choose a circumcenter which
might be on the boundary if i want to
if i want to uh explore i want to choose
a cost in the middle of the set and
middle defined by distance to the
boundaries
and then i and then i'm going to force
nature to cut through it
so we call this inverse exploration
because we don't really have control of
information gain
but the cause regret nature either needs
needs to cut this guy or at least move
it to the boundary
and
and we can choose
a c we can choose a proxy cause that
forces nature to pick one of them either
nature gives us regret or nature gives
us information
so it's a different way of learning than
like in classical statistical learning
because the way this is type the way
your control is by forcing nature to
choose one of them either nature causes
regret or gives you information about
where you should go
and the circumcenter actually is a trap
that really policy fails
because you your your knowledge starting
evolves by incorporating half phase cuts
and you end up having this polyhedral
thing and when you have a polyhedral
object very easily the circumcenter ends
up on the boundary so you don't want to
be working with polyhedral cones
so the technique that we do is we
regularize the knowledge set
and we're going to replace these
knowledge sets by superset the container
and in particular we're going to use
ellipsoidal cones to do this and this is
a technique we use in the other paper on
contextual pricing there was like
ellipsoids and here's ellipsoidal cones
but you can you can sort of like
you can work with these and why why are
lip cytophones nice because now if you
think of my set as an ellipsoidal cone
then my axis
which is the point further away from my
binder is also my circumstance
so i i force nature to
i don't have that trade-off with these
kinds of sets between explore and
exploit
let me do it on time okay good um
so the basic of the algorithm is you
have a an uncertainty set which is an
ellipsoidal cone you choose a proxy cost
based on it then you choose an action
based on this structure cost and then
you collapse this feedback
and now we do something a little bit
delicate here
which is you update this code only if
this difference in actions here
is sufficiently informative in a new
direction
so you're going to have two types of
periods here you have low regret periods
when this is not very when this is not
very informative i just take the regret
and when this is very informative i get
i update and i get uh
i gain information and why why do we
need to have this knowledge with no
regret periods that's kind of the cost
of using ellipsoids because ellipsoids
have a tendency to become
your condition so if i cut this thing
and it starts shrinking this way it
starts becoming long in this direction
so it's a known thing of the ellipsoid
method and if you sort of like say i'm
not going to do cuts in small directions
you can avoid this problem of your
condition
and and to make this work we needed to
adapt the ellipsoidal method to work on
the ellipsoidal cones and i'm not going
to go into the details here it's not
trivial but but it's all in the paper
and this gives me a regret that's d
square log t tangent of my initial
of the initial uncertainty angle
so this technique works but only if my
initial uncertainty angle is small
now the question is can we relax this
and um
and that's what we're gonna do next
so
if we start from uh from like a
non-pointed set what happens here
so if i have like lots of dimensions
nature can play a game with me and what
is a game that nature can play nature
can send me nature can like ignore one
of their dimensions so let's say i have
three dimensions nature only plays in
these two dimensions so it only gives me
information in this dimension so i never
learned anything about the vertical
dimension so i never get a pointed set
what can i do
in this case here where nature is sort
of like playing this game with me and
trying to avoid me from learning
nature can't give me a regret in this
based on this dimension if he never uses
it
so what we do is we ignore unused
dimensions
if nature decides not to use dimension
we don't get regret from it so what
we're going to do is say look we're just
going to work in the subspace where
nature has given me uh information on
and this idea of projections is also
present in the literature so so we're
sort of like we're combining these
techniques from the literature
but but we have to use it a little bit
differently here
and and we're going to keep track of the
subspace and what happens here
if
i get some information that's close
enough to the subspace
i'm going to ignore the orthogonal
elements of this and i'm going to do a
little cones in that period i'm going to
sort of like do that ellipsoidal cut
i have to be a little bit careful here
because now i'm throwing away some
information so so there's some error
that i introduced in the process so i
need to robustify this process and if
you know the lip side method there's
this technique called shallow cuts to
make it more robust
like you don't cut through the middle
but you cut just part of it off so we
can we can robustify the technique
and
but if nature gives me a delta t that's
far enough from from here i can uh
update my subspace
and now i have three types of period
there's no
these like periods where i get low
regret
these periods where i do a i update my
information within my subspace
and i have these periods where i do this
dimension update where i move to higher
dimensional space
that i'm keeping track of
and
viper
and the the challenge here is you want
to do this dimension update only if your
information said it's sufficiently far
away from this delta because there's a
trade-off here because you you want to
keep a gap because if if you do an
update and you have very little
information on the dimension you're
gonna you're gonna get something that's
very non-pointed in that dimension but
if you also do a big thing here and you
don't do an update then you have a lot
of error in your local subspace update
in your local cone update
so there's a gap there's a trade-off
that we need to sort of like optimize
between
like saying if this how far this needs
to be from the subspace for me to do an
update whether i want the subspace
updates to be better or the phone
updates a bit better so there's
a ton of technical details here that uh
obviously i'm not gonna get through
uh but the high level message is this
this works so this costs a sum in
dimensions right so the last the last
algorithm was d square log t times the
tangent here i can get rid of the
uncertainty set so i can actually
this technique here this more
complicated version of the algorithm
works for any of
uh initial knowledge set
and it's the first log regret for this
class of problems here
so um summary of online learning so
the technique that we did is that sort
of like we first started with offline
learning and i argued that you should
you should build that that
uh
cone around your uncertainties set
and
your circumcenter policy was a greedy
policy there
and this doesn't work because we also
needed uh something to force nature to
explore right because if you do the
circumcenter you might end up on the
boundary and once you're in the boundary
you're trapped because nature can make
sure you don't learn
and we can make this policy work by
making a number of adaptations
we can replace the polyhedral sets which
are bad for learning with ellipsoidal
cones and then we can adapt the
ellipsoid method to work with the
ellipsoidal cones
and then we skip the knowledge stats on
all regret periods to avoid these
ellipsoidal cones from getting your
condition
and then
we maintain the subspace where there's
no we maintain a subspace where the
knowledge where the knowledge sets are
pointed
and you combine this all you get a lot
of regret for this problem
so what are some takeaways from uh from
this problem here which is uh
there's this
uh classical bandits you always assume
you observe rewards but there's problems
in practice where we're very interested
that they're very interesting like
learning from review preferences where
you don't observe
uh
rewards but you just in the end and the
particular case that we want to explore
here they're exploring these papers is
learning from optimal actions and it's
sort of like this interface of or and
machine learning discussive problems
and it gives rise to
a novel family of algorithms so there's
like all sorts of like new things that
we can do here
track of these problems and the way
learning happens is very different than
statistical learning it's called in this
literature this is sometimes called the
imitation learning and
the way you drive exploration is by
forcing nature
to explore for you if you don't want to
give your regret
and um
i saved a few minutes at the end to talk
about a different paper because
everybody here is talking about
marketplace interference so i decided i
need to pitch my marketplace
interference paper here too
yes
many applications you can think of
here
for example
yeah can we say anything
well these bones apply right so i don't
can you do better
i mean you
this for honey paper is uh
this honey paper is uh
is a stochastic version of this and
there you you get these you get designed
um
instead of having these things that are
like worst case you have the cvr type
constraint
and you can go
you can do really well there so it's a
it's a different framework but yeah so i
think in the spirit of like jumping from
sarcastic to
there is a whole spectrum of from this
worst case to
to a fully sarcastic yes
i'm pretty sure it's not optimal
so day to day for uh we lose one day so
uh we lose one d from going from uh just
from the lip side method
and and we lose two more days when the
subspace updates one of them is like you
gotta count the number subspace and
another one comes from
the pointedness of the set when you do
the updates
it's plausible that there is something
here i mean the
the
even the life is not obvious that it's
optimal right so like the contextual
search and pricing papers i did we ended
up at log t
but then other people like renato and
john schneider ran out of slammage on
schneider they did log log t right and
you're saying there's even uh
possibility of going uh
uh boundary like a finite regret here
i'm not claiming any of this is optimal
what i'm claiming
is the frontier was square root t
and we were able to push it to the log
fee
i i wouldn't be surprised if there's a
lot more teeth but if you look at the
you have to see how i mean i know you're
aware how much work it goes into like
pushing from longitude to log block t so
it's perfectly possible that there is a
future paper that will push this further
that's a great question
there is no i don't know any lower
bounds on this problem that's in like
how hard it is
so
it's really possible that maybe thinking
a different type of center
although sacrificing a little bit in the
offline exploitation might actually be
better in terms of
hedging
yeah yeah so there's one way that i
think you can easily gain a d here
is instead of doing
the ellipsoidal things you just choose
you keep up on the hebrew set
and then you choose a vector that's kind
of like far away from
that's kind of like somewhere an
interpolation between the circumcenter
and the point further away from all the
boundaries
that's just a lot harder to keep track
of because this point hypothesis has
become really messy right actually the
same thing like and
specifically the thing with the spinal
fluid
right like there's this whole little
picture of like yeah and that's how
spikes let me and schneider improve the
other one yeah this was using steiner
this yeah so if i map this maybe to that
setup now what that would require is
that like your quote-unquote feasible
region of points as convex at each point
together yeah i'm not assuming anything
here yeah i know you're not yeah so
one of the beauties here is that we're
working with like a really
adversarial study and the only thing we
assume is that the context function is
lipschitz but the feasible set of
actions is arbitrary could be an integer
programming problem
but
i totally believe the claim that there
are better algorithms for this problem
than this
so great open questions
i might have a simple question um i mean
in this in this problem setting at every
step you you have the action set and you
have the function and you observe the
oracle
first action later yeah and that allows
you to cut down the
down the unit sphere a little bit at
every step
um
i'm just i'm just confused about i mean
that's the best you can do and that's
the most information you can get from
all the history um
so so i'm just a bit confused about the
trivial part of this problem setting
what is non-trivial here
yeah
because because every and every step you
can cut down the unisphere a little bit
and uh i think that's so yeah but but
the main the main idea the main insight
is i think your question is a good one
because it looks like really should work
and it doesn't it feels pretty miserably
and the idea that and i think the key
inside that that that when we crack the
problem is that you need to sort of like
make sure that your point is somehow in
the middle of the set and that forces
nature to cut through the set
and then you can learn
i think that's
i think that's that's the sort of like
the key inside that allowed us to get
traction with this problem
was this idea that like if you're you
you need to somehow
don't do something greedy which looks
like it works after it but it doesn't
right so we did all these experiments it
wasn't working and then we started like
trying to figure out why
and uh
and i forgot to put here on the slides
but you already have that all the
simulations this works fast and better
than what did the
on
funds and simulated data
have a question yeah
about the model uh so you have both the
context function which is known and the
set of actions which is
yeah uh is this
um
could you model it as just like you have
a set of you know vectors that deal with
the new stuff is doing a functional
approach to this it's possible that yes
there is other ways to formulate this
that are potentially more powerful okay
so i'll give you that
yeah
it's a great question
so now let me i have like five minutes
so let me teach you a different paper
because everybody here is thinking about
interference in marketplaces and i feel
like hey i have a paper in this too
so this paper is with you the bride who
is at lyft and arthur de la route who
was at lyft but he's now at georgia tech
was a postdoc
and when we started working on this
paper at the beginning of the year
um all the papers were either there was
honda's team that worked with airbnb we
do invent steam they work with amazon
and they all work with these like
choice-based marketplaces and what am i
calling choice-based marketplaces these
are marketplaces where interference is
super hard to model because if you if
you do the thing that vivec and hana
were describing where you you treat half
the people and then you suck up the
houses and that causes an interference
on the other half it's really hard to
know how the control people are going to
respond to that
uh but i was working with lift guys and
they're like look our marketplace is not
like that at all
in a when you order a car or lyft or
let's say we order deliveries on
doordash or something you press a button
and say hey
send me some food or send me a driver
and there's some optimization that is
run to dispatch
a car to you or a driver to your
delivery
so the
main argument in our paper is
it's a lot easier to do interference
control here than here
it's actually quite this
and
and in particular the main result that
we have is that if you're in a matching
based marketplace
like if your dispatch is if if the way
uh interference happens is via a
dispatch problem for example because
think about an uber or lift case
you have the same interference right if
treatments are targeting more your head
don't have as many cars control is going
to order less because they're going to
have less availability longer etas
you're going to have all these problems
so you have exactly the same issue of
interference but here in the setting you
know exactly what the interference looks
like
and what i mean you know exactly what
the interference looked like you're the
experimenter you're also uber or lyft
you know
the linear program you use to dispatch
people
so you can use the linear program to
correct things and the correction that
we come up with is really simple it's
just do your analysis in the dual space
instead of doing your analysis in primal
space instead of adding like all three
that miners all control you do
you take oh you you look at your
matching linear program you let's and
then you look at like the shadow prices
of all the tree that minus the shadow
price of all the controls
and we proved that this is actually the
correct first order taylor series
approximation correction here
so you get like you still have a little
bit of error you still have like a
second order ear but you get rid of the
first order ear and the idea is is
what is the dual than the program the
due of the program is the value of a
treated unit or the value of a control
unit depending on which dual which
control constraint you're using
and
and the technique works amazing so for
this one i did for the simulations here
uh so the technique works amazing
because this is uh we did this like ride
share experiment like a whole day worth
of data and if you don't correct let's
say you have an effect size of 10 if you
don't correct if you have very little if
you have very little requests you don't
have a lot of interference you're fine
now if you're in a very dense
marketplace now suddenly if you don't
correct you're pretty far off
and the diamonds here are what our
method does so this is without
correction this uh there's the solid
line is a true result and the diamond
that's almost at the right spot is our
is a result of our uh method here
so um
that's it thank you very much
i